welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
boss and I'm excited to partner with
Spotify to bring you this breakdown of
episode one of the Riddler secrets in
the dark the new audio Thriller that
follows the Riddler played by Hassan
Minaj this version of the character last
heard in the Spotify podcast series
Batman unburied is actually a reluctant
Ally to the bat family helping out
Barbara Gordon and Alfred through the 10
episodes of that series Minaj has said
that the series will be equally
surprising because instead of the Batman
saving the Riddler Batman needs the
Riddler to help save the bat from
certain death and this time finally The
Riddler gets the spotlight that he
deserves we open fittingly enough with
the Riddler dropp in a riddle what
disappears the moment you say its name
lights out the answer
is silence and to that Riddler we get
the hilarious response more of the
man all the cells in Arkham and I
ended up next to your American ass